donc je me débrouillais enfin d'accord
le plus dur quand on monte un one man
show s'est fait rare 10 font tous les
matins quand je me réveille tous les
matins quand je me réveille je me lève
et je te bouscule et tué la veille par
un peu comme d'habitude avant de monter
sur scène je suis souvent en coulisses
on peut rire de tout sauf on peut rire
de tout sauf si c'est pas marrant si un
jour j'ai un fils je l'appellerai si un
jour j'ai un fils ou une loge
l'appellerait
une fois par an j'ai bien ce que je
préfère chez moi c'est ce que je préfère
chez moi c'est mon canapé la dernière
fois que j'ai pris de la coke
mais enfin que j'ai pris de la coke m'en
souviens pas très bien parce que je
devais être sous acide je ne sais pas si
je dois le dire ou non je sais pas si je
dois le dire ou non alors je crois que
je vais pas le dire
ce que j'aime chez les antisémites a
sérieusement
voilà un truc que j'aime bien avec les
antisémites moi j'aime bien parler avec
les antisémites
vraiment j'adore ça parce que quand je
parle avec des juifs j'entends que des
problèmes c'est les problèmes qu'on a en
france et les problèmes avec les
mariages mixtes les problèmes avec les
guerres israélo-arabes les problèmes
avec d'accord je parle avec des
antisémites j'entends que des bonnes
nouvelles c'est les juifs qui ont tout
l'argent c'est le jura they do in a
l'habitude abonnez vous il m'était
impossible eux